20 septembre 1946 car ne veut devenir la
capitale du cinéma international
après une tentative avortée en 1939
cette première durera jusqu'au 5 octobre
au lendemain de la guerre
l'heure est à la fête charles et feux
d'artifices inondent la ville sur la
croisette pavoisée aux couleurs des 19
nations participantes la classique
bataille de pleurs après lui les au
groupe édition des maîtres films choisis
dans la production de chaque pays
pour cette première en automne la
compétition opposait les pays comme leur
vision aujourd'hui 19 nations venait
défendre les films qu'elle avait
sélectionné pour maurice bessy
scénariste et directeur de la revue ciné
monde
cette dimension internationale était
primordiale le but tim duncan est une
manifestation d'autant plus importante
qu'elle est pacifique et internationale
depuis plusieurs années en raison de la
guerre les différents films
internationaux n'avaient pas pu être
confrontés et c'est la france qui a pris
l'initiative de réunir les plus
importants des différentes nations cette
année là parmi la quarantaine de films
en sélection officielle
un long métrage français tire son
épingle du jeu la bataille du rail de
rené clément remporté deux prix
toute la vie secrète violent d'héroïque
des cheminots pendant que la france
vivait sous le couteau nazis vous la
connaîtrez dans le film qui a obtenu
l'unique grand prix international du
jury au festival de cannes et dont le
réalisateur rené clément a été désigné
par le même jury comme le meilleur
metteur en scène internationale pour
l'événement des dizaines de vedettes de
cinéma débarque à cannes pendant quinze
jours la ville devient mondaine et
touristique
les marques s'empare aussi du phénomène
et organise même des défilés sur place
il
pendant encore cinq ans le festival de
cannes ouvrira à la fin du mois de
septembre
il faudra attendre 1951 pour connaître
la première édition printanière
[Musique]